willkommen zur aktuellen Sendung im
Seminar philosophische Theorien der
Aufklärung heute geben wir erst einen
kurzen Rückblick auf die letzte Sendung
da mache ich dann auch oben rechts den
Link rein in der ging es um den
aufklärungsbegriff bei Moses Mendelssohn
über die Frage was heißt aufklären die
Vorgeschichte kennen die ZuschauerInnen
Zuschauer schon es ging um eine
provokative Frage eines Theologen mit
dem Namen Zöllner der sich darüber
gewundert hatte was eigentlich
aufgeklärt bedeutet weil in einem
anderen Kontext über die bürgerliche
zivil-ehe dieser Begriff verwendet wurde
wonach eine kirchliche eh gar nicht mehr
nötig sei das sei nicht aufgeklärt
aufgeklärt sei die zivile wo eben diese
Frage auftaucht was eigentlich
aufgeklärt bedeutet und er hat hier ein
Text geschrieben dieser Herr Zöllner ist
es ratsam das eben Bündnis nicht ferner
durch die Religion zu sancieren und
unten rechts hat er hier einen kleinen
eine kleine Fußnote gesetzt und
geschrieben was ist Aufklärung diese
Frage die Beine so wichtig ist als was
ist Wahrheit sollte doch wohl
beantwortet werden immer aufzuklären
Anfänger und noch habe ich sie nirgends
beantwortet gefunden das war sozusagen
der Auslöser für eine ganz große Debatte
für verschiedene Schriften die sich zum
Ziel gesetzt hatten Aufklärung zu
definieren und man könnte jetzt sagen
dass auf im ersten Schritt nur so viel
bedeutet wie überhaupt zu erklären was
Aufklärung bedeutet also die Definition
des Begriffs die ist der erste Anfang
der selbst Aufklärung über sich selbst
der Selbstvergewisserung der
Selbstkonstitution eines aufklärerischen
Programmes das heißt es hat eine
Selbstreflexivität und auch eine
kritische Dimension gehört immer dazu
heute soll es jetzt um ein ganz
bekannten Philosophen gehen der in
erster Linie mit dem Thema Aufklärung in
Verbindung gebracht wird um Immanuel
Kant Beantwortung der Frage was ist
Aufklärung auch aus dem ähnlichen ja
wenn du sowas 1783 er macht 1784
alles in derselben Umgebung der
zeitlichen Umgebung hier sieht man das
Stück er bezieht sich wie Mendelssohn
auf diese Ausgabe in der
berlinischen Monatsschrift
wo eben der Herr Zöllner diese Frage
aufgeworfen hatte
er bekennt auch ganz am Ende seines
Aufsatzes das er bereits auf die
Beantwortung der Frage bei Mendelssohn
gestoßen ist bzw darauf hingewiesen
wurde aber er selbst hat Mendelssohns
Beantwortung dieser Frage noch nicht
lesen können und er fragt sich ob
eventuell der Zufall eine Einstimmigkeit
der Gedanken zu Wege bringen könne also
ob letztendlich beide auf denselben die
selbe Definition
kamen bezüglich des Begriffs der
Aufklärung das heißt Mindestlohn und
kann haben im selben Jahr sitzt seit 84
Reaktion auf eine Schrift im Jahr 1783
ihre Antwort darauf gegeben wir ein paar
Leitfragen wie bestimmt kann den Begriff
der Aufklärung wie wenn sich aufklären
und Vernunft nach Kant zueinander und
wie verhält sich ganz aufklärungsbegriff
zu demjenigen bei Mendelssohn
ich bringe jetzt hier ein paar ganz
zentrale Zitate und habe die wichtigsten
Begriffe darin fährt hervorgehoben kann
bestimmt das kennt man so im
Schulkontext bereits Aufklärung als
Ausgang des Menschen aus einer selbst zu
schütten Unmündigkeit
Unmündigkeit definiert er jetzt ist das
Unvermögen sich seines Verstandes ohne
Leitung eines anderen eine anderen
Person Instanz zu bedienen und
selbstverschuldet ist die Unmündigkeit
weil diese Ursache für die Unmündigkeit
nicht in einem defizitären Zustand
nämlich das mangels des Verstandes liegt
sondern in einem anderen Defekt der aber
letztendlich zurechenbar ist wenn wir in
unserem Verstand eingeschränkt sind wenn
da ein Mangel am Verstand ist dann
können wir dafür ja nicht dann kann man
uns ist ja nicht selbst vorwerfen ja
wenn wir einfach ein provokativ gesagt
zu dumm sind dann kann man das nicht
sagen dass wir selbstverständlich sind
wenn wir einfach
kognitives Defizit haben anders ist es
bei dem Mangel der Entschließung und des
Mutes
ohne Leitung einer anderen Person sich
unseres Verstandes zu bedienen dieser
Mangel jetzt der Mangel an Mut und
entschließung der ist obwohl es ein
Mangel ist und selbst unser freien
Entscheidung zu regelbar weil wir unsere
Freiheit nicht genug gebrauchen sind wir
dennoch dafür verantwortlich sein kann
und das ist ganz zentral deswegen sagt
der Audi das heißt lateinisch vage ist
zu wissen oder wie er es formuliert habe
den Mut dich deines eigenen Verstandes
zu bedienen und das ist nach kann sogar
der Wahlspruch der auf den also das ist
das Motto sozusagen unter dem auf den
verstanden werden muss also seine
Aufforderung ist Imperativ
könnte jetzt wieder hier fragen wie
verhält sich diese Imperativ zum
kategorischen Imperativ ich glaube da
gibt's gewisse Ähnlichkeiten das würde
jetzt aber zu weit führen dass genauer
zu betrachten und man könnte natürlich
auch sich fragen ob es sich hierbei um
eine Form von Normativität handelt ich
mache oben rechts in den es gibt den
Link zu meiner Vorlesung über das Thema
Normativität herein weil da ja ein
gewisses ideal ein gewisser
sollensanspruch an uns herangetragen
wird also aufklären scheint eine
normative Angelegenheit zu sein die
gelingen oder nicht gelingen kann
er macht jetzt Faulheit und Feigheit als
Ursachen aus für unsere Unmündigkeit und
er sagt es ist zu bequem es ist so
bequem unmündig zu sein und jetzt kommt
eine ganz interessante Diagnose die
glaube ich nichts an Aktualität
verloren hat sondern die absolut zentral
gerade auch für die heutige Zeit ist er
sagt nämlich habe ich ein Buch was für
mich verstand hat ein Seelsorger der für
mich Gewissen hat ein Arzt der für mich
beurteilt so brauche ich mich ja nicht
selbst zu bemühen er sagt sogar ich
brauche nicht mal zu denken wenn ich nur
bezahlen kann das heißt kann verbringt
hier verschiedene Medien mediale
Instanzen ins Spiel die letztendlich
dafür verantwortlich sind dass wir nicht
genug Mut aufbringen um selbst zu denken
diese mediale Vermittlung unserer
Aufklärung kann man natürlich sehr gut
auf die aktuelle Zeit beziehen
Buch da steht natürlich das Internet im
Hintergrund und das Geld ist auch
zentral wir können mit Geld praktisch
alles tun und uns dadurch natürlich auch
von unserer eigenen Verantwortung
entlasten das ist ein Problem des Geldes
er bringt jetzt hier noch einen weiteren
Punkt er sagt nämlich dass diese ruhigen
Geschöpfe die
letztendlich in ihre Unmündigkeit
gefesselt und Geschöpfe ja kein Schritt
außerdem gängelwagen der gingwagen ist
ein Gestell mit dem kleine Kinder laufen
lernen als eine Art von Unterstützung
dass sie außerdem Gänge wagen sich nicht
getrauen nicht wagen einen Schritt zu
tun und den Engel Wagen sagt er sind sie
eingesperrt die unmündigen Menschen
dass sie zu sehr Angst haben alleine zu
gehen er vergleicht also letztendlich
die aufklär mit dem selbstständigen
gehen lernen eines kleinen Kindes was
aus den gängelwagen also der sehr
verschulteten Unmündigkeit heraus geht
diese dieser Vergleich mit der Bewegung
die mit hervor der Bewegung des sicheren
Ganges wird uns noch in anderen Zitaten
begegnen ist sehr zentral für seine
aufklärungstheorie er sagt nämlich
es Satzungen Formeln sind mechanische
Werkzeuge eines vernünftigen Gebrauchs
oder Missbrauchs Naturgaben die sind zu
Fuß Schellen also Fußfesseln einer
immerwährenden Unmündigkeit geworden das
heißt da wird unser Gang letztendlich
gemindert uns ergangen wird darin
beschränkt wir sind unfrei unserem Gang
durch diese Satzung und Formen die wir
uns natürlich nicht selbst wirklich
autonomen gegeben haben sondern die uns
heteronom entgegenstehen und durch die
eine freie Bewegung letztendlich und ein
sicherer Gang nicht möglich wird
jetzt sagte während ein Individuum sich
nicht gut selbst aufklären kann ist es
für ein Publikum als eine Gemeinschaft
eine Öffentlichkeit viel besser er sagt
ein Publikum kann langsam zur Aufklärung
gelangt da steckt natürlich wieder der
Bildungsbegriff im Hintergrund und eine
Revolution also ein plötzlicher Umsturz
das bedeutet ja Revolution ein Grund
Setzen des Ereignis das ist verkannt
nicht die Lösung für die Aufklärung
sondern nur eine allmähliche Reform der
Denkungsart
Reform und Revolution muss man hier nach
Kant streng unterscheiden
und die Ziel der Aufklärung ist nach
Kant letztendlich die Freiheit wichtiger
Begriff Freiheit Autonomie und zwar
bestimmte die jetzt folgendermaßen von
seiner vernünftigen allen Stücken
öffentlichen Gebrauch zu machen wir
hatten schon in der letzten Folie
gesehen Öffentlichkeit ist ganz wichtig
und jetzt sagt er hier
nur der öffentliche Gebrauch erlaubt ist
uns aus der Selbstverständlichkeit
herauszukommen und er muss jederzeit
frei sein
und er bestimmt diesen öffentlichen
Gebrauch der Vernunft als denjenigen den
jemand als Gelehrter von ihr der
Vernunft vor dem ganzen Publikum der
leserwelten Macht und er unterscheidet
diesen öffentlichen Gebrauch der von uns
von Privat gebraucht den eine Person in
einem gewissen ihm anvertrauten
bürgerlichen poste oder Ernte von seiner
Vernunft machen darf das heißt im
Privatgebrauch dürfen wir nicht oder
sollen wir nicht alles mit unserer fünf
machen da müssen wir uns an die Regeln
halten die uns bürgerlich privat in
einem bestimmten Beruf vorgegeben ist
das ist letztendlich eine instrumentelle
Situation wo wir als Mittel zum Zweck
dienen müssen der kategorisch Imperativ
sagt wir sollen nicht nur als Mittel zum
Zweck gebraucht werden deswegen sagt
kann soll auch immer der öffentliche
gebrauchte vernünftig sein
vor dem ganzen Publikum der leserwelt
hier kann man sich natürlich fragen ob
in heutigen Zeiten nicht auch jedes
Internet oder wie zum Beispiel jetzt
eben auch Youtube
gemeint sein kann ob das nicht auch in
öffentlicher gebrauchter Vernunft ist
und ob man das immer auf eine gelehrte
Person beziehen muss das stellt sich mir
auch diese Frage ob oder ob man das
nicht ausweiten kann auf alle möglichen
hintergründig erscheint Gelehrter sehr
weit zu verstehen einfach im Gegensatz
zum bürgerlichen Posten Gelehrter ist
der Freigeist der nicht gebunden ist in
seinem Denken an bestimmte Vorgaben
eines Berufes oder einer Position er
steht der Gelehrte über diesen
Funktionen und kann frei reflektieren im
Sinne der Aufklärung
jetzt fragte sich Leben wird einem
aufgeklärten Zeitalter er verneintes
nein aber wohl in einem Zeitalter der
Aufklärung das heißt es tut sich schon
etwas im 18 Jahrhundert aber es ist
natürlich im dieser sukzessiven Reform
der Denkungsart noch nicht vollendet es
ist ein längerer Prozess der Bildung zu
Aufklärung er beschreibt diesen
Prozess der Verbreitung der öffentlichen
Hüft als Geist der Freiheit der sich
ausbreitet und er entwickelt ja ein
Ideal dass der hang- und Beruf zum
freien denken sich allmählich auf die
Sinnesart eines Volkes also staatlich
auswirkt und auch am Ende auf die
Grundsätze der Regierung die ist ihr
selbst zugänglich findet den Menschen
der nun mehr als Maschine ist seine
Würde gemäß zu behandeln also am Ende
wendet er sich hier auch gegen lameterie
und seine Theorie der menschlichen
Maschine